brought to you by total war warhammer
colossal battles addictive empire
building hundreds of hours of strategic
gameplay order now and get chaos
warriors free hey guys I'm Dave and
welcome to your war hammering in two
minutes this video is totally brought to
you by our total friends over at total
war a game series that has been firmly
rooted in the realms of realism until
now back in 1983 when war hammers
created it was played on the tabletop
using painstakingly painted figures and
a rule book about as thick as an orc
skull come forward 30 odd years and all
those painted figures are now computer
rendered hordes so whether you're a
warhammer fan or not I'm going to show
you how these guys can make up some of
the biggest armies in the Warhammer
universe so you can start marching your
autumn vampires after victory total war
war hammer is based on the eighth
edition of the long-running tabletop
hobby and with over 30 years of Lords
draw from the game features tons of
unique and vastly different races but
the big players who you need to know
about are the Empire the dwarves the
greenskins the vampire counts and the
chaos warriors the Empire is your
classic kingdom of men complete with
Knights cavalry men in shiny armor and
funny-looking hats but with the addition
of badass Imperial wizards and men that
ride into battle on the backs of Demi
Griff's saw that supernatural stuff
aside just like real men these folks
have a fear of things that go bump in
the night except this time those things
are real and only a few days march away
the vampire counts are you guessed it
the undead vampiric Lords and
necromancer's lead terrifying armies of
zombies skeletons and vicious monsters
the spread corruption across the old
world the dark powers these guys wield
can even raise the dead turning any army
they defeat into more mindless infantry
to send against their enemies as their
vampire rulers feast on the living
although even the hungriest vampire
might think twice before sinking their
teeth into a stinking org greenskins is
the umbrella term to describe both the
brutal orcs and the cunning goblins
these absolutely barbaric savages want
nothing more than to fight scrap and bra
with any race to death stand against the
green tired or if they're really bored
they'll just fight amongst themselves
like squabbling children but with
muscles and giant foul teeth they pretty
much hate everyone
but they really hate the dwarves
tinkerers and weapon Smith's these short
bundles of muscle often stay in the
mountains underground amongst all of
their dwarven tech little legs aren't
much good for running so they are the
slowest and most offensive of the bunch
and probably also the grumpiest as any
time someone slides them they write it
in their big book of grudges so they
make sure to remember to get revenge yes
they're that petty and the baddest dudes
of all the bad dudes are the forces of
chaos men and beasts that have been
warped by the twisted powers of the Dark
Gods into foul forms their former selves
a roaming horde from the corrupt wastes
of the world whose only goal is to raise
the world in the name of their masters
and usher in the end times
so that should prepare you for all the
coming Wars a head and yes before anyone
asks there is an actual war hammer it's
this a few years ago people love to make
fun of me for painting Warhammer but now
look how far we've come sure people
still making fun of me but there are
plenty of Awesome Warhammer games for
more on total war war hammer make sure
you keep your eyes open for lucy's
reality check and the gist with Jess and
if you want to nerd out with me you can
find me on Twitter at a regular Dave
thank you so much for watching and I'll
see you next time
you